to our chronovirus coverage now here at  noon and it is a crucial day today for  the u.s  in the fight against the coronavirus an  fda advisory panel is meeting right now  to review pfizer's coronavirus vaccine  for emergency use  if it's approved the first shots could  come within days  two people who received this vaccine in  the uk experienced reactions earlier  this week  both had a history of severe allergies  and both recovered  we're working very closely with our uk  partners to understand  what went on with respect to those  allergic reactions  the meeting comes a day after the nation  reported more than 3 000 people died in  a single day here in the u.s  nationwide coveted hospitalizations are  at their highest levels  ever they are up nearly 80 percent in  just the past month